Here are Smarter Every Day, we've
decided to change the format
and make learning very very serious.
And by serious I mean...
[Thump, splash]
- Seriously awesome!
[Crowd yells]
[Crowd laughs]
(Destin) Alright, today we're
gonna learn about mud in Africa.
They build houses out of mud.
I went to Africa. Let's talk about it.
(Destin) I don't know. I don't
know when I can come back.
(Man) We're glad to have you to come back.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
You come, we can make house me and you.
- Oh yeah. And we'll live in the house.
- Yeah.
We'll call it King of Dragons' house.
- Yeah. And Destin.
- And Destin.
[Laughs]
(Destin) So burlap?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- You see?
- Yeah.
- Oh no. You're picking all that up?
- Yes sir, no problem.
- Ugh. King of Dragons.
Nothing for the King of Dragons.
- He's my younger brother.
- Oh. He's very helpful.
- Yeah, he's very strong.
[Foreign language]
- Do you need the shovel?
Oh, only with your hands.
- Only with your hands, yeah.
- Are hands better?
- Yeah. Hand is better for this one.
When you're making blocks
you use your hands.
- Why? Why do you use your hands?
- Because hands can make this all.
If you want to make blocks here,
this type of blocks...
- Yes.
- Once you make block you use, so...
You see?
When you put it inside, you remove it.
Now, [unintelligible].
- Yeah?
When you get-- when it get full...
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- Does it hurt your hands?
- No.
[Unintelligible] ...my hand.
[Destin laughs]
(King of Dragons) You pick it up.
- How do you keep from uh...
from making it slump?
Oh, perfect.
- You see?
- Perfect.
- You see? Is nice?
- So the amount of water is important.
- Yeah.
(Destin) Doesn't straw make it stronger?
- Yeah, this one holds [unintelligible].
- You don't need straw.
- No.
- That's a lot of blocks.
- 440 blocks, maybe.
- 440?
- Yeah.
(King of Dragons) 35 cm.
- So it's twice as long as it is wide.
- Yeah.
Is very nice?
- Very nice.
- You love it.
- I do. Thank you, Ishmella. Thank you.
(Destin) Yeah, Matt just chipped a tooth.
Spearing me in the mud. Totally worth it.
Was it worth it?
- It was totally worth it.
[Destin laughs]
- Thanks, Matt.
- You're welcome.
[Music]
...Feedback loops,
so you have to know your position
and where your relative motion is
going, so you can compensate for it.
Well, chickens are really
good at this, so...
I'll show you. Watch his
head stay totally stationary
as I move his body. I can move his
body in pretty much any direction.
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.